here's what the war in ukraine taught us
about bitcoin
crypto fans sometimes talk about war and
societal collapse as positive for their
cause
some see them as a haven others talk
about them as hedges against inflation
there's even a view that such events
could lead to the eventual demise of the
us dollar as the world's dominant
currency with something like bitcoin
taking its place
so how was crypto impacted by russia's
invasion of ukraine
what's the evidence that the war led to
a furthering of this narrative
it's mixed at best
in the initial phase after troops
invaded in late february the currency
did not climb alongside well-known
havens like gold and the swiss franc
instead its performance was lackluster
even a collapse in the ruble didn't
immediately lead to an influx of money
into crypto
during the later phases as tensions
eased it rallied however and that
suggests
that it's acting as a risk-on not a
risk-off asset
and its correlation with yields on
inflation-adjusted treasuries a proxy
for expectations of future inflation
didn't strengthen either
instead bitcoin and other cryptos echoed
the moves of the shares of technology
companies like twitter
so did the war undermine the dollar
some say it did particularly the use of
sanctions which may hasten what the imf
has described as a stealth erosion of
the dollar as the top reserve currency
but that's not benefited bitcoin
instead
russia attempted to take payment for its
commodities in rubles and shored up on
gold
traditional fiat currencies like the
euro yen and pound remain the only real
challenges to the dollar the lesson
seems to be that investors should cut
through the hype and see cryptos as they
really are
risky and volatile digital assets which
potentially offer tremendous long-term
growth
i'm eddie van der walt this is decrypted
for more content like this follow us on
your favorite platforms